so I have another question for you are
you emotionally involved with chocolate
do you just love chocolate would you
like to know why there's something in
this chocolate that's giving you a
pleasure sensation
there's over 380 chemicals but of those
380 there's three that mainly create
this effect let's start from the top
first one is called phenyl alanine so
what actually is this phenyl alanine
it's really just a building block to
make dopamine okay
dopamine is a neurotransmitter it's a
hormone like substance that travels
through the nervous system in the brain
which is different than actual hormones
that travel through the blood
okay so dopamine is the main
neurotransmitter that's elevated when
you take drugs so it's a mood enhancer
phenyl alanine also can increase
endorphins endorphins are chemical
compounds that give you the state of
euphoria or it just like an uplifted
feeling now phenyl alanine can also
increase something called Noor
adrenaline which is similar to
adrenaline but this neurotransmitter
just helps you feel awake it's involved
in a lot of chemical processes but it's
gonna actually just wake you up it's
gonna make you feel more alert then we
have something called theobromine and
don't worry there's no bromine in
theobromine and the Greek word for Theo
is God and bromo is food so this word
comes from the concept of the food of
the gods
okay theobromine is a very similar
chemistry to caffeine with a slight
little difference so there is caffeine
and chocolate but there's more
theobromine so it's a stimulant it
increases mental clarity focus it's also
a diuretic so it's gonna make you pee
more it's a vasodilator now the problem
is if your liver is damaged so let's say
for example you have a fatty liver or we
have cirrhosis or hepatitis whatever
you're not gonna have the capacity to
rid theobromine or even caffeine for
that matter out of the liver as fast as
you should so if you're consuming just a
little bit of chocolate let's say later
in the day or before you go to bed
you're not going to be able to sleep
because the stimulants gonna
a lot longer then we have tryptophan
okay this is an amino acid which is a
precursor for serotonin so it turns into
serotonin that is a neurotransmitter
that will give you the stain of
well-being it makes you feel calm it
reduces stress it's gonna help if you're
under anxiety if you're depressed it'll
bring you up and this is why people
consume chocolate when they're depressed
because it's an it's it's gonna elevate
your mood so there's a lot of other
nutrients in chocolate that are good for
you and as long as you're not doing too
much of it I think you're gonna be fine
but you just want to make sure you don't
consume it too late in the day where
it's gonna keep you up at night and of
course I don't need to say this but if
you're new to my channel I need to say
this you never want to consume chocolate
with all the sugar lose weight too much
sugar in chocolate it's like 30 grams
per bar so that's way too much you wanna
buy chocolate that's sugar-free so when
I say sugar-free I'm not talking about
using multi tall for example that's
really really high on the glycemic index
so it can really raise your blood
Sugar's you want to get chocolate with
other alternative sweeteners like a
wreath rotol stevia monk fruit emule in
xylitol those are totally fine all right
well thanks for watching and also go
ahead and comment below if you have a
severe addiction I'm sorry an emotional
relationship with chocolate I want to
know thanks for watching
yeah you should keep questioning things
because sometimes she's but the real big
problem with chocolate is this sugar
okay so what what so I have another
question
are you what
[Music]
hey guys I'm not sure if you have my app
yet dr. Berg app it's totally free you
should download it okay this is what it
looks like you click it it gives you all
sorts of great resources I have all my
YouTube videos on this out ok and it's
regularly uploading the most recent ones
all the YouTube videos are also
converted to audio versions ok so you
can use it when you're walking
exercising driving your car I have a
mini course on there I'll be putting
additional courses I have a lot of
recipes on there this is new and also
PDF resources so there's various
downloads PDFs that you can get as well
and if you wouldn't mind after you
download it check it out
give me your unbiased review and tell me
how you like it
I want to know